it's great to be joined today by Jackie
say--let who is an advocate for the
rights of independent voters also
president of independent voting which is
the largest network of independent
leaders and activists in the US with
organization in 40 states Jackie I think
a good place to start before we get into
third parties is maybe talking a little
bit about independent voters there's
sometimes the idea that by virtue of
being an independent voter you're either
a centrist or in some way neutral
between conservative and political ideas
for the most part that's not true though
right I mean for the most part
independent voters have no party
affiliation but they do still tend to be
on one side or the other of the
political spectrum in my experience
independents span the entire political
spectrum from right to left when you ask
them about social issues or policy
issues those kinds of things
however the bond that ties independents
together and you know as you know this
is now 44 percent of the country who
identify themselves as independents the
bond that ties them together is a belief
that the political system is broken that
the parties serve largely their own
self-preservation and not the the
purpose and the mission of representing
the interests of the American people and
they have declared themselves to be
independents because they want to make a
statement about that
sure and I guess my point is and I'm
curious whether whether you would agree
that an independent party is sometimes
thought of as a definitive centrist
party but that in reality that there's
no rule that that that says that that's
the way it would have to be you have
lots of independents that are on the
right and even to the right of the
Republican Party you have lots of
independents that are certainly to the
left of the Democratic Party and a would
you agree that it would be wrong to
assume that an independent party of any
substantial size would be necessarily
simply a centrist party between
Democrats and Republicans
I would totally agree with that let's
talk a little bit about the sort of
practical paths towards third party
growth and engagement I've pointed out
in the last several years that I think
that there are two major impediments to
growing the number of votes for third
party candidates at least in
presidential elections number one is
campaign finance and sort of how
politics is financed in the United
States and number two it's the lack of a
voting system like an instant runoff
voting system that would allow someone
to more easily support the candidate
that their politics most closely aligned
with with my which might not be a
Republican or independent without
possibly ending up helping the candidate
they most disagree with assess my
assessment of those two items I think
look in the last 25 years or so there
actually have been independent parties
that have exploded and I and I do use
the term exploded purposely onto the
political scene most notably I think the
Reform Party in the 1990s that was the
political party that grew out of what's
known today as the Perot rebellion after
Ross Perot Rose first run in 1992 and
for a period of about five or six years
there was the framework shall we say of
of a third party that was
non-ideological in its orientation that
was reform oriented and its mission and
I brought together people across the
political spectrum across geographical
divides ideological divides
socio-economic divides etc and and had a
brief shining moment if you will as as
as a new not just a new party but a new
kind of political party now for a
variety of reasons the Reform Party was
destroyed and disabled after this
six-year experiment and I was a part of
that and it was you know an
energized and controversial political
effort controversial in a lot of
political circles so I think that when
you when you point to barriers and
surely those barriers are there from
ballot access to the fear of spoiler
voting to campaign finance regulations
to debate regulations to the ways that
elections are administered namely as a
bipartisan rather than a nonpartisan
affair and so on and so forth all of
that comes into play there's no question
about that and I think that part of
what's going on right now in the reform
movement and in the independent
political movement is there's a lot of
energy and a lot of attention being paid
to what kinds of structural reforms are
necessary in order to make it more
possible for a third force to emerge
whether it emerges as a party or not
that's kind of an interesting question
frankly because given that the sentiment
of so many Americans particularly
independence but not exclusively is to
be disappointed and distressed by the
parties and by the kinds of partisanship
that they produce it's not altogether
clear to me that a third party is going
to be or should be the form that a new
force takes
oh yeah well so I think it's interesting
imagining that because you do have
independents who are not Republicans or
Democrats because they don't want to be
part of either of those two parties
there are also independents who are sort
of against the concept of political
parties and those are two different
things and it's important to distinguish
yes and I would add I'm not agree with
you and I think that that's very true
they're not just against the concept of
political parties they're just against
activities corrupt authoritarian
controlling structures that limit
competition and are completely focused
on you know their own political power
over the interests of ordinary people
they're against that and so then the
issue becomes well what are we going to
create that does give
well a platform and tools to fully
participate in what is supposed to be a
self governance process in this country
but which frankly the parties are one of
the major obstacles to realizing that so
Jackie and your sort of context right is
the do you think that the independent
that there's this sort of stereotypical
or carriage and caricatured independent
who says something like well I'm
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative so therefore I'm not a
Republican or a Democrat I'll just vote
for whichever Republican or Democrat is
closest to my views that's not really
sounding to me like the type of
independent that you're talking about or
targeting right why do you say that well
because you seem to be more focused and
not as a criticism but you seem to be
more focused on those who are
independents not because they share
views with some democrats and
republicans but rather because they feel
that the infrastructure that exists
between these two parties and the
corruption that sort of inherent to our
political finance system or the problem
it's not about I'm kind of with the
Democrats on some issues and with
Republicans on others but it's a
different paradigm altogether that's
what I'm gathering tell me if I'm wrong
I see no well that's true I think that's
accurate though i I guess the one caveat
I would add here is that I actually
think that most Americans are socially
liberal broadly defined I agree and
fiscally conservative broadly defined
so don't naturally agree on that part
get talked about in in a somewhat
elevated way or or a categorical kind of
way but I mean you know I think in in
people's personal and private lives and
family lives you know everybody has to
manage a budget and you're only allowed
to borrow but so much you know and most
people have looked kind of
live-and-let-live attitude and a you
know and and somewhere between
libertarian and and you know progressive
if you want to use that kind of language
view of social issues but I think in a
way maybe me
the point that you're making and here I
think it's very important is that the
parties and the structure of the parties
actually prevent people from coming
together across the ideological divide
you know one of the things that in my
experience in Reform Party for example
which was a true left-right coalition
was that we talked a lot about the
building a bridge between the overtaxed
and the underserved for example and and
finding that there was actually a
tremendous commonality of interest in
purpose among many different kinds of
Americans but the party system really
channels people into a kind of divide
and and I think that's part of what
we're grappling with and I think again I
think independents have an important
role to play in helping the country as a
whole
reshape some of these paradigms and
create some new tools for us to deal
with all of this in a different way
Jackie in the limited time we have left
I'd love your brief thoughts on whether
2020 presents an interesting opportunity
for independent voters and possibly for
something other than just a Democrat and
a Republican as a result of the sort of
chaos that the Trump presidency has sort
of sown whether that's a challenger from
within the Republican Party that ends up
running third party or in some other way
do you think that the 2020 election has
some interesting opportunities for
independence I think it does I think it
raises a lot of really important
tactical issues and if you will
developmental issues for the country but
yeah there's a huge amount of chaos and
both parties are in chaos by the way not
just Trump's party but the Democratic
Party is as well and you have this huge
swath of Americans that are out there
that are not aligned with any political
party there's I think there's a basis
for some new and you know and pretty
pretty explosive things Apple we've been
speaking with Jackie say--let she is
president of independent voting and a
super interesting topic that we've been
covering for a long time Jackie I really
appreciate you talking to me today
well thank you so much for inviting me
it was great talking to you too